bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo de pourquoi sont ils si
unique aujourd'hui nous allons nous
attaquer à un mastodonte de l'univers
marvel un antagoniste que vous m'avez
beaucoup demander et à juste titre il
s'agit de l'homme le plus dangereux du
monde doctor doom le docteur doom c'est
probablement le vilain le plus connu et
le plus mémorable de marvel c'est
l'antagoniste ultime du célèbre groupe
des 4 fantastiques
il est un personnage très riche et très
complexe et je suis très heureux de vous
mettre en lumière son histoire
aujourd'hui surtout que bah voila quoi
on attend son arrivée dans le mc
néanmoins avant que la vidéo commence
j'aimerais quand même vous avertir
l'histoire de dom et ultra longue il y
avait clairement un désir à l'époque
d'en faire le vilain iconiques de la
saga et du coup bah ce dernier possède
une omniprésence dans l'univers il est
même un comics qui à l'époque sur sa
couverture pour le troll nous disait que
doctor doom n'était pas dedans donc
c'est pour vous dire à quel point le
personnage est présent dans l'univers du
coup voilà le concept de l'émission est
quand même de démontrer à quel point tel
ou tel personnage est unique donc même
si on va quand même retracé l'histoire
de doom dans les comics marvel voilà on
va quand même faire des sauts dans le
temps pour plus se focaliser sur les
gros événements de sa vie bref donc
écouter ne tardons pas plus longtemps
parlons de l'homme dont la volonté lui a
permis d'atteindre le divin voyons
ensemble pourquoi doctor doom et sims
[Musique]
il
nous sommes le 10 avril
1962 et ce jour marque la sortie du
cinquième volet de la saga de comics
fantastique fort une saga pilier dans
l'histoire des comics car l'arrivée des
quatre fantastiques dans leur série
dédiée marque le début d'une nouvelle
ère c'est le moment où va naître une
véritable continuité dans l'univers ou
plusieurs personnages de comics
différents vont commencer à se
rencontrer et c'est même l'une des
premières fois que marvel va nous
proposer une véritable team de super
héros qui travaillent ensemble et du cou
qui dit nouvelle ère et nouvelle team
dit forcément l'intégration d'un nouveau
grand méchant et c'est ce qui va se
passer dans le comics fantastique fort
numéro 5 là bas nous y retrouvons les 4
fantastiques dans leur quartier général
au centre de new york comme à leur
habitude la torche et la choses sont en
train de se chamailler et reed richard's
alias monsieur fantastique ainsi que sue
storm la femme invisible intervienne
pour les séparer sauf qu'ils ne le
savent pas encore mais vont le découvrir
très vite un lugubre personnage équipé
d'une sinistre armure de métal et d'une
cape verte est en route pour les
confronter il s'agit du docteur doom
depuis son hélicoptère doom par le biais
d'un fil électrique va recouvrir
l'entièreté du building des 4
fantastiques sachant l'équipe de
super-héros aux prises au piège
l'antagoniste va commencer à prendre la
parole pour faire part de ses
revendications et c'est alors que coup
de théâtre reid richard's va reconnaître
la voix de ce nouvel ennemi celui qui se
fait appeler le docteur doom s'appelle
en réalité
victor vendôme et il était élève dans la
même université que reed richard's
monsieur fantastique va nous en dévoiler
un peu plus en nous révélant que le
jeune homme était un brillant
scientifique très attiré par la
sorcellerie et la magie noire et une
nuit dans sa chambre alors que victor
cherchait à rentrer en contact avec les
enfers il va perdre le contrôle de sa
machine
et cette dernière va créer une
gigantesque explosion qui aura pour
résultat de défigurer le jeune victor et
le conduira par la suite à son expulsion
la dernière fois que red richard's aura
entendu parler de victor von doom il
était apparemment en train de parcourir
les dangereuses montagnes du tibet dont
le but de découvrir les plus grands
secrets de la magie noire mais étant
donné que plus personne ne l'a jamais
revu reid le pense est mort de retour
dans le présent le docteur doom va
enlever sue storm pour s'en servir
d'otage et qu'il n'appellera le reste de
l'équipe pour les emmener dans son
château là bas en position de force dont
on va nous révéler qu'il soit en fait se
servir des 4 fantastiques pour récupérer
un trésor dans le passé qui était détenu
par le célèbre pirate barbe-noire par le
biais de sa machine à voyager dans le
temps qu'il a créé doom va donc envoyer
monsieur fantastique la torche et la
chose pour réaliser la mission dans
cette époque lointaine nos héros vont
réussir à se fondre dans la masse grâce
à des déguisements de pirate et après
quelques péripéties atterriront sur le
bateau de barbe noire qui est en train
de se faire attaquer grâce à leurs super
pouvoirs les fantastiques réussiront non
sans mal à contrer la tacc reed et john
y est rond par la suite dans la cale
pour essayer de trouver le fameux trésor
c'est alors qu'à leur retour ils seront
témoins d'un drôle de spectacle
la chose se fait acclamer par tout
l'équipage qui scande le nom de barbe
noire nous sommes en fait face un
paradoxe à cause du voyage dans le temps
et de leurs actions dans le passé la
chose est devenue barbe noire et là au
final toujours été car dans le futur
quand le nom de barbe noire est
mentionné il est en fait fait mention
des actions de la chose dans le passé de
retour dans le présent doctor doom va
nous révéler le contenu du coffre ce
dernier contient des pierres rares
appartenant autrefois au célèbre
magicien merlin et qui lui permettrait
d'accéder un pouvoir qui le rendrait
invincible suspectant la dangerosité du
trésor reid richard's dans le passé a en
fait de vider le contenu du coffre et
quantum va s'en apercevoir la chose va
se mettre à l'attaqué néanmoins les 4
fantastiques ne connaissent pas encore
assez bien leur nouvel ennemi doom
s'attendait à ce genre de rébellion
depuis le début nos héros font face à un
robot talent effigie du dr doom le
véritable se cache dans une pièce
adjacente
malheureusement ayant toute son
attention focalisée sur vie de johnny et
ben sous réussi à se faire oublier et va
mettre à mal le plan du docteur doom
puis libéré tous ses amis pris de court
le docteur n'aura d'autre choix que de
s'enfuir des laissant derrière lui sa
machine à voyager dans le temps et son
château bon vous commencez à connaître
la tradition rien qu'avec ce premier
comics nous pouvons déjà souligné des
éléments intéressants concernant le
personnage effectivement on ressent déjà
clairement que le docteur doom n'est pas
un méchant comme les autres et qu'il a
le potentiel pour se hisser en tant que
futur très grande menace avec la récente
apparition des 4 fantastiques qui en
plus ont pour objectif de devenir très
centraux dans l'univers marvel stan lee
et jack kirby voulait véritablement leur
dédier un grand méchant récurrents et
qui surpasse tout ce qu'ils ont connu
jusqu'à maintenant mais ce n'est pas
tout bien que le groupe des 4
fantastiques est important le personnage
central de l'équipe reste quand même
reid richard's présenté comme l'un si ce
n'est le protagoniste le plus
intelligent du monde et le leader des 4
fantastiques sidhoum a pour but de
devenir le nouvel ennemi principal de
l'équipe des fantastiques il doit donc
être également le plus grand ennemi de
rides richard's et c'est déjà quelque
chose qui est souligné dans ce premier
comics victor von doom est un brillant
scientifique comme read richard's quand
monsieur fantastique souhaitera devancé
doom en vidant le contenu du coffre nous
prouvant sa supériorité doom va
reprendre l'avantagé en le devançant lui
aussi prévoyons qu'il allait se faire
trahir et au final c'est le travail
d'équipé qui l'emportera stan lee et
jack kirby ont également relier les deux
personnages de par leur passé d'étudiant
pour approfondir leurs relations et leur
donner des points communs mais pour
éviter que dom soit la copie conforme de
riz en version parc victor n'est pas
simplement un scientifique il est aussi
un sorcier et c'est là où la naissance
du némésis de rides peut se faire car
bien évidemment la magie rentrer en
opposition avec la science et dernier
point important c'est la fameuse machine
à voyager dans le temps on ne se rend
pas forcément compte là tout de suite
mais le fait que doctor doom et
découvert le voyage dans le temps déjà
cela prouve à quel point c'est l'un des
plus grands cerveaux de son erp mais
surtout cela aura un impact immense sur
l'univers marvel et notamment concernant
certains personnages que je pense vous
connaissez bien doctor doom réapparaîtra
dans la suite directe du comics que je
viens d'énoncer cette fois-ci
l'antagoniste traqué par les 4
fantastiques ira à la rencontre de namor
pour salir à lui pour faire face à leur
ennemi commun
au final nos héros réussiront à
raisonner le seul marine heures qui
trahira doom dont la défaite le fera
dérivés a découvert dans l'espace dans
le comics 10 sorti le 9 octobre 1962
nous nous retrouvons dans le bureau de
stan lee et jack kirby eux mêmes ces
derniers sont en pleine recherche d'un
vilain pour confronter les 4
fantastiques
c'est alors qu'ils vont penser au dr
doom car pour eux je le rappelle il est
censé être le nouveau vilain iconique
malheureusement ce dernier est perdu
dans l'espace sauf que surprise grâce à
la magie de la facilité scénaristique le
docteur doom débarque dans le bureau de
ses créateurs comme si tout était normal
l'antagoniste va par la suite demandé à
jack et stan de convoquer reid richard's
et le docteur doom va profiter de
l'occasion pour le kidnapper une fois
réveillé double révélé à son ennemi ce
qu'il s'est passé après sa dérive dans
l'espace ce dernier s'étant fait
accrocher un astéroïde qui l'a emmené
dans une autre galaxie là-bas le docteur
sait faire récupérer par des êtres qui
se font appeler les eaux voice
clairement au dessus de l'humanité en
terme de savoir de civilisation et tout
ce qui s'ensuit 12 va bénéficier de la
connaissance des eaux volts pour
parfaire ce compétences il va nous
révéler finalement qu'avec ce nouveau
savoir il est désormais en capacité
d'échangé de corps et c'est pourquoi il
a kidnappé reid une fois infiltré dans
le groupe des 4 fantastiques dôme depuis
le corps de reed va mettre au point une
machine permettant de réduire ses
adversaires à un état subatomiques sauf
que reed ne se laissera pas faire et à
terme la vérité va éclater et une fois
que chacun aura récupéré son corps
d'origine les quatre fantastiques
retourneront larmes subatomiques de doom
contre lui ce qui aura pour effet de le
réduire à l'état d'atomes bien
évidemment vous vous en doutez nous
sommes très loin de la fin du dr doom et
les 4 fantastiques vont très vite s'en
rendre compte dans le comics 16 doom
réapparait ce dernier a en fait tu
atterris dans le micro et routeurs une
dimension où règnent l'infiniment petit
la ba dum grâce à son génie va réussir à
se hisser en tant que nouveau dirigeant
du royaume écartant le roi et la
princesse des commandes il va ensuite
attaqué les 4 fantastiques depuis le
micro au world et les attirer vers ce
nouveau monde finalement grâce à l'aide
de la princesse et dante man qui est
l'expert de l'infiniment petit nos héros
à réussiront à faire fuir doom du micro
ou world quelque temps plus tard dans le
comics 17-12 va connaître sa véritable
première apogée ce dernier a mis au
point à tout nouveau plan pour mettre à
mal les 4 fantastiques et l'humanité
dont il souhaite prendre sa revanche
après avoir récupérer l'adn de nos héros
le docteur douma va kidnapper alicia
master's la petite amie de la chose pour
faire points de pression sur l'équipe
ses ennemis désormais sur le banc de
touche donne va commencer à attaquer le
gouvernement des états-unis en a quand
le système de défense et d'armement du
pays dont il va prendre le contrôle puis
il va exigé la reddition complète de ses
dirigeants étant dans une période de
pleine guerre froide les russes seront
témoins de ce qu'il se passe dans le
pays de leurs adversaires et alors
qu'ils devraient se galvaniser d'une
telle situation et bien c'est tout le
contraire car ils savent que s'ils doom
est capable de faire plus à lui tout
seul les états unis les russes seront
les suivants pendant ce temps là à
durant toutes ces péripéties reid
richard's dont le gouvernement appelle à
l'aide est à la recherche d'une solution
ce dernier va faire la découverte que la
protection du vaisseau du docteur doom a
été conçu à partir de l'adn des 4
fantastiques
ce qui veut dire que si l'un des membres
ose s'approcher de trop près il sera
exécuté
instantanément monsieur fantastique va
alors avoir l'idée ingénieuse d'utiliser
une potion temporaire permettant de
rendre à la chose sa forme humaine car
son adn ne sera plus le même durant
cette période grâce à ça les 4
fantastiques vont pouvoir s'infiltrer
dans le vaisseau libéré alicia et
défaire le sinistre docteur doom par la
suite le docteur réapparaîtra dans le
comics the amazing spider man numéro 5
où ce dernier tentera de s'allier à
l'oma régner avant de s'en servir comme
otages face aux quatre fantastiques 12
novembre 1963 doom sera encore là pour
nous prouver une fois de plus sa
suprématie et son intelligence
l'antagoniste va réunir trois des plus
grands criminels des états unis et grâce
à sa technologie va leur donner des
pouvoirs qui contre ceux des 4
fantastiques
le groupe sera donc battu non sans mal
mais à terme tout va mal tourner pour le
docteur doom qui dans un dernier espoir
pour vaincre ses ennemis jurés va lancer
une onde solaire qui va consumer le sol
est piégé ce qui chute dans l'espace les
quatre fantastiques qui commence à bien
connaître le fonctionnement de leurs
ennemis réussiront à retourner la
situation en leur faveur et c'est doom
lui même qui va chuter dans l'espace et
c'est désormais à partir de maintenant
dans le comics fantastique fort annuel
numéro 2 sorti le 2 juillet 1964 soit
plus de deux ans après l'intégration de
doom dans les comics que nous allons
enfin avoir une véritable origin story
concernant le personnage et vous allez
le voir il y avait clairement du mystère
concernant ce dernier à l'époque il y
avait vraiment un désir de faire de doom
une entité profonde est supérieur à la
plupart des méchants que nos héros de
comics ont déjà pu confronter le jeune
victor valdes au mas est un enfant
d'origine
s'ils gagnent ce dernier mène sa petite
vie en compagnie de son père qui est en
quelque sorte le soigneur du groupe il
est un expert de la nature et des
potions étant bienveillant et reconnu
par ses compatriotes
la réputation de werner le père de
victor le précède très souvent à tel
point que le baron du château adjacent
au camp deegan enverra ses soldats pour
obtenir l'aide du soigneur car la femme
du baron est très malade malheureusement
la baronne a atteint le point de non
retour ces dernières est trop gravement
malade et est beaucoup trop faible pour
être sauvé sauf que le baron ne veut
rien entendre et pire que ça déjà qu'ils
n'aiment pas les tziganes qu'il
considère comme inférieurs pour lui si
vernon eure n'arrive pas à la sauver ce
sera alors la faute du soigneur et ce
dernier sera tué sur le champ werner va
alors tout tenté pour sauver la baronne
et au moins alléger les souffrances de
la jeune femme mais sachant sa cause
perdue après avoir répondu à la demande
du patron il va retourner au camp et
emportera victor avec lui dans une
cavale qui est malheureusement
inévitable comme il l'avait prédit la
femme du bar on va mourir quelques temps
après son intervention et le baron dans
une colère noire va envoyer la totalité
de ses soldats aux trousses du soigneur
l'accusant d'avoir assassiné la baronne
après des jours de cavale werner aura
finalement réussi à échapper à la garde
du baron cependant en donnant tout ce
qu'il avait pour protéger victor ce
dernier va s'effondrer avec son fils et
c'est boris un ami proche de la famille
qui finira par les découvrira
inconscient dans la neige werner
poussera son dernier soupir et victor
qui a réussi à survivre grâce à l'amour
et la protection de son père entrera
dans une rage folle depuis sa naissance
il a été témoin de l'injustice dont sa
famille a été victime depuis toujours
les 10 gagnent sont persécutés et
considérées comme inférieures
par les gens puissants du monde à cause
de la tyrannie victor a finalement perdu
ses deux parents qui étaient des gens
simples bienveillant et altruiste
l'humanité doit donc payer tous ceux qui
ont fait du mal à sa famille et ses amis
doivent répondre de leurs actes boris
devenant le nouveau parents de victor va
donner aux jeunes garçons les affaires
appartenant à ces défunts parents et à
ce moment précis quelque chose de très
intéressant va se produire au moment de
la mort de bernard ses derniers mots ont
été que victor devait protéger quelque
chose il n'a malheureusement pas pu
terminer sa phrase et victor enragé a
compris qu'il parlait de lui en mode il
faut protéger victor son fils de ce
monde cruel qui nous persécute depuis
des années
sauf que c'était pas véritablement ce
que werner vous laisse sous-entendre
boris qui est un ami proche des ventes
doublent et surtout de werner a compris
ce que le soigneur voulait dire au
moment de son décès son ami était un pur
altruiste il passait sa vie à rendre le
monde meilleur en soignant les gens
grâce à ces remèdes et ses potions ce
qu'il voulait dire au moment de sa mort
c'est que victor devra protéger le monde
héritée de son père et prendre le bon
chemin car en fait il nous sera révélé
que la mère du jeune vendôme était en
fait une sorcière et que malheureusement
à cause de la magie la mère de victor a
pris un mauvais chemin qui la conduira à
sa propre mort la magie entre de
mauvaises mains ou de mauvaises
intentions peut conduire aux pires
atrocités c'est en faisant face aux
affaires de ses défunts parents que
boris sera témoin du futur choix de
victor qui symbolisera l'entièreté de la
nouvelle vie du jeune garçon alors qu'il
essaie d'orienter victor à reprendre les
remèdes et les potions de son père dont
il se servait pour faire le bien victor
toujours enragé est convaincu que la
gentillesse de son père a été la
faiblesse qui l'a conduite à sa mort va
finalement ignorer les potions de son
père et faire la découverte d'une malle
appartenant à sa mère qu'il a très peu
connu victor va donc comprendre qu'elle
était en fait une sorcière il va faire
la découverte de potions magiques et
autres secrets liés à l'alchimie et la
science ayant désormais tous ces
nouveaux savoirs à portée de main victor
va délaisser tout ce qu'il a pour se
tourner vers l'héritage de sa mère
devenue désormais un adulte la rage de
victor ne s'est jamais éteinte alliant
la science et la magie victor pour
venger son père est épaulé par boris va
piéger et humilié d'innombrables lord m
ou autres personnages de pouvoir il va
par exemple faire payer des fortunes à
ces gens en leur fournissant des
artefacts magiques et quand la vente
sera effectuée il les détruira à
distance ou bien quand c'est tour héron
trop loin poussant le candy gagnent à se
faire attaquer victor par le biais de
ses inventions réussira toujours à
repousser l'ennemi bref le jeune victor
commence à écrire sa propre légende et
tout comme son père sa réputation va
commencer à le précéder ce qui va
conduire un grand scientifique américain
à aller à sa rencontre
très impressionné par les créations de
victor et suspects un véritable génie
l'américain souhaite que victor partent
avec lui pour qu'il devienne un de ses
élèves dans sa prestigieuse université
de sciences bien évidemment le jeune
garçon va accepter issu d'un petit candy
gagnent victor a la possibilité de faire
une ascension fulgurante où il peut
devenir l'un des talents prometteurs
d'une des plus grandes universités des
états unis désormais étudiant le jeune
homme va commencer à croître ses
connaissances et ses compétences
il va même faire la rencontre d'un
certain reid richard's qui encore jeune
et timide cherche à se faire des amis
sauf que voilà victor n'oublie pas son
passé si il est dans cette université
c'est clairement pour devenir plus fort
entre guillemets il n'a que faire des
autres étudiants c'est alors que reed
toujours dans les pattes de victor va
faire la découverte de la fameuse
machine qui vous le savez va exploser
des figurants victor et le pousser à son
expulsion de l'université sauf qu'avant
tout ça reid qui comme je le disais
essayé de traîner avec victor va jeter
un oeil aux calculs de ce dernier sauf
qu'il sera témoin d'une erreur dans une
équation le jeune vendôme déjà très imbu
de lui même va totalement ignoré la mise
en garde de rides sauf que son camarade
avait vu juste les calculs étaient
incorrects et c'est pourquoi la machine
a explosé désormais livré à lui même
victor va se diriger vers le tibet comme
l'avait dévoilé son premier comics après
plusieurs jours de marche dans la neige
et le froid victor au bord de la mort va
s'effondrer sauf qu'en fait il a atteint
son but une mystérieuse tribu cachés
dans les montagnes dont personne n'a
entendu parler depuis des siècles va
recueillir le jeune fantôme et le
soigner victor va se reconstruire petit
à petit il va devenir même le leader de
la mystérieuse tribu et à prendre tous
leurs secrets ayant désormais atteint
tout le savoir dont il avait besoin pour
être un nouvel homme la science de par
l'université la magie de par la
mystérieuse tribu le jeune vendôme va
concevoir une armure de métal pour
cacher le seul défaut qui lui reste son
visage est pour nous montrer sa
supériorité
alors que le masque est encore chaud
victor va l'appliquer sur son visage
ignorant totalement la douleur atroce
que ça doit lui infliger ce jour là
victor vendôme est mort pour laisser
place à sa nouvelle identité qui fera
trembler le monde le dangereux dr doom
après son voyage au tibet doom
retournera auprès de boris la seule
personne qui a toujours veillé sur lui
devenu quelqu'un de suprême le docteur
va reprendre le royaume de la latvérie
et s'ériger en tant que nouveau
souverain de la nation seul dans son
château doctor doom est devenu le roi
puissant et charismatique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui respecté par son
peuple
comme je vous le dis à chaque fois avoir
une véritable origine story permet de
mieux s'attacher et de mieux consolider
le personnage est il apporte nous
retrouvons énormément de thématiques qui
caractérise l'antagoniste doctor doom la
confrontation d'intelligence et des go
avec reed richards concernant les
équations nous démontrons du coup que
reed et l' équivalent si ce n'est
supérieur à doom en termes de science
les profondes blessures internes
concernant les parents de victor à cause
du main considérant les y gagnent comme
inférieures poussan donc victor à passer
de moins que rien à entité la plus
dangereuse du monde ou encore la
thématique de la perfection il ya
quelque chose que j'adore chez le
docteur doom et stan lee le penser lui
même mais en gros la plupart des gens
pensent que derrière son masque victor
est complètement moche et défiguré alors
qu'en fait ce serait peut-être pas le
cas bon il est clair qu appliquer un
masque en fusion sur son visage ça
laisse des traces mais avant ça à
l'incident de l'université il se
pourrait que victor et subit une simple
petite cicatrice mais étant obnubilé par
la perfection et sa supériorité c'est
toute petite marque sur son visage le
pousserait à pété les plombs car cela
anéantirait l'idéal qu'il a en tête et
qui le symbolisent est néanmoins en tout
cas sachez que le comics fantastique
fort annuel numéro 2 n'est pas fini bien
que le comics nous et partager une
véritable origine story du personnage
et bien ce dernier nous amène quelque
chose d'autre de très intéressant
effectivement en rappelez vous mais doom
dans le comics 23 des 4 fantastiques
s'est retrouvé une fois de plus dans
l'espace a dérivé sauf que cette fois ci
pas d'astéroïdes et pas de quatrième
eurent brisé pour ramener le personnage
doom là est actuellement en train de
mourir or un an auparavant sur un comics
un peu particulier c'est le comics
numéro 19 des 4 fantastiques sortie le 9
juillet 1963 c'est le comics qui va nous
présenter l'antagoniste rama tout et
rama tout pour ceux qui ne le savent pas
c'est l'une des identités de nathaniel
richard's qui précède celles de quang le
conquérant pour la faire courte les 4
fantastiques ont voyagé dans le temps
par le biais de la machine de doom pour
trouver une ancienne fleurs capable de
rendre la vue à leurs amis alicia
master's l'hérault vont faire face à un
drôle de pharaon qui va leur révéler
qu'il a tant fait lui aussi voyager dans
le temps une confrontation va éclater
entre les personnages et rama tout aura
pour seule issue de prendre la fuite via
sa machine temporelle et c'est là que
tout devient intéressant au moment de
quitter la terre rama tout va tomber sur
le docteur doom en train de dériver et
mourir dans l'espace curieux de voir qui
est ce drôle de protagonistes rama toute
valeur ramener dans son vaisseau et une
conversation va s'engager entre les deux
antagonistes doctor doom va raconter
rapidement son histoire et sa récente
défaite face aux quatre fantastiques qui
explique pourquoi ils se retrouvent à
dériver dans l'espace c'est alors que
rama tout sera complètement interloquée
car il connaît très bien le nom de
docteur doom provenant d'un lointain
futur il explique que s'il a pu voyager
dans le temps c'est grâce aux travaux
d'un vieil ancêtre appeler docteur doom
effectivement comme je vous disais on ne
se rend pas forcément compte mais le
fait que doctor doom et découvert le
voyage dans le temps possède un impact
incroyable sur l'univers des comics nous
prouvant au passage encore une fois sa
supériorité son génie le voyage dans le
temps est un concept riche mêlant à la
fois le passé le présent et le futur
rappelez-vous du paradoxe du premier
comics intégrant doom la chose à cause
du voyage dans le temps nous a démontré
qu'il était lui-même barbe noire car il
a voyagé dans le passé et du coup plein
d'autres personnages vivront
similairement la même situation doctor
doom est en fait la personne qui a donné
naissance à quang le conquérant car à
cause ou grâce à sa machine nathaniel
richard's va pouvoir comprendre et
appréhender ce concept depuis son
lointain futur et je tiens de fou à le
souligner car il est clair que stan lee
et jack kirby voulait faire de um un
antagoniste suprême et simplement par le
biais de ses expériences et son génie
doom nous démontre à quel point il est
omniprésent dans l'univers et chacune de
ses actions possède un impact sur
l'histoire et ses personnages le docteur
doom reviendra par la suite dans un
nombre incalculable de comics déjà rien
qu'avec l'histoire de rahmat tout une
fois revenu sur terre doom chercheur à
confronter une ultime fois reid
richard's pour savoir qui est l'homme le
plus intelligent du monde reid réussira
à duper son ennemi en lui faisant croire
qu'il l'a enfin tuer après s'être rendu
compte de la supercherie est
l'antagoniste reviendra dans fantastic
fort numéro 39 et 40 où il confrontera
les 4 fantastiques alliés a dardé ville
lors du mariage de rides richard's et de
sue storm dans le comique ce fantastic
four annuals le numéro 3 dont on va
mettre au point une machine capable de
changer l'émotion des gens et du coup il
va s'en servir pour que la totalité des
ennemis des 4 fantastiques et des
avengers vienne gâcher le mariage créant
donc une immense bataille opposant la
totalité des héros de la terre face à
leurs ennemis dans avengers ce numéro 25
sortie le 9 décembre 1965 doom fera
l'objet de la première véritable
confrontation face à l'équipe des
avengers en tant que ville en 1966
toujours dans la saga des 4 fantastiques
le docteur doom va réussir à voler la
planche du surfeur d'argent banni sur
terre par galactus faisant de lui
l'homme le plus puissant du monde le
docteur sera tellement devenu inquiétant
pour les autres pays qu'il va déclencher
une guerre mondiale entre la latvérie le
petit pays dont il est le souverain et
le reste du monde à terme reid réussir à
détourner la victoire en guidant doom
vers l'espace ou la planche du surfeur
n'a pas le droit de se diriger car
noreen rad est bannie et ne peut pas
quitter la terre ce qui provoquera la
chute de doom quelques temps plus tard
en 1968 le comics avengers annuals
numéro 2 fera son apparition et pour
être honnête avec vous dôme n'est pas
dedans alors pourquoi j'en parle et bien
parce que ce comics nous démontre
l'impact global que possède doctor doom
sur l'univers marvel un impact qui
touche même les plus grands méchants en
gros vous vous souvenez de la rencontre
du dr doom avec rama tout est bien ici
c'est la première apparition du scarlett
centurion et pour les connaisseurs vous
savez déjà qui est ce personnage
scarlett centurions c'est en fait la
prochaine identité de ram a tout juste
avant de devenir kangs le conquérant
rama tout après sa rencontre avec le
docteur doom dont il est convaincu avoir
des liens de parenté se sont inspirés
par ce personnage charismatique dont la
machine à voyager dans le temps lui a
permis de devenir qui il est aujourd'hui
rama tout va donc délaissé son identité
de pharaon et se construire une armure
inspirée de celle du docteur doom pour
ressembler à ce dernier sauf que bien
évidemment il ne peut y avoir qu'un seul
docteur doom le passage de nathaniel
richard sens car les centurions sera un
fiasco et sera très vite délaissé pour
laisser place à l'identité de quang le
conquérant bon je vous avoue que
personnellement je pense qu'il y avait
un véritable désir des créateurs de fer
s'émanciper le personnage pour qu'il
devienne une entité qui se suffit à
elle-même aucune utilité de faire un
doctor doom bis qui en plus de ça est
moins bien que l'original donc voila
quand naîtra mais c'est intéressant de
souligner à quel point l'influencé de
doom est énorme on se février 1969 sur
le comics marvel super heroes numéro 20
le dr doom est en train de s'entraîner
dans son château pour sa future
confrontation avec les 4 fantastiques
sauf qu'un démon du nom de diablo un
expert de l'alchimie va faire son
apparition comme toujours la réputation
de doom le précède et diablo souhaite en
fait s'allier à doctor doom pour
conquérir la terre bien évidemment
endoume est imparfait solitaire se
considérant supérieur à la grande
majorité de l'existence ce dernier n'a
aucune envie de s'allier à qui que ce
soit et encore moins un vieux démons qui
vient quémander de l'aide néanmoins
diablo avait prévu cette possibilité
afin de faire plier doom à sa volonté
diablo va révéler au docteur qui l'a
kidnappé une jeune femme du nom de
valeria sur le coup on se dit bas et
alors qu'est ce que doom peut bien avoir
à faire de cette jeune femme et bien en
fait ce n'est pas n'importe qui valeria
et la fille de boris l'homme qui
accompagne dôme depuis toujours et en
plus de cela c'est le grand amour de
jeunesse du docteur et du coup tout est
chamboulé pour le docteur doom car
effectivement les années ont passé ses
limites c'est sa période en tant que
victor vendôme ce n'était pas une autre
vie carrément c'est une véritable claque
nostalgique que se prend le docteur
retrouvant des émotions enfouies
derrière son armure doom va finalement
s'exécuter et s'allier à diablo pour
sauver valeria il va finalement réussir
à se débarrasser du démon et sauver la
jeune femme est là nous allons faire
face un grand moment sentimentale
valeria nous révèle que cela fait des
années qu'elle attend ce moment elle a
toujours aimé victor et ne l'a jamais
oublié sauf qu'aujourd'hui
victor n'existe plus seul le docteur
doom a survécu valeria dans son
désespoir cherchera à convaincre le
docteur de redevenir le jeune homme
plein de vie et ambitieux qu'il était
quand il était encore amoureux mais
les années ont passé le visage marqué de
doom traduit l'histoire lourde qu'il a
vécu depuis qu'il est parti du camp les
conquêtes son règne à la ddt vérifia le
pouvoir qu'il a acquis en délaissant ses
émotions c'est tout ça dum aujourd'hui
victor n'existe plus et ne reviendra
jamais et malgré l'amour qu'il porte
toujours dans son coeur pour valeria le
monarque restera muré dans son silence
laissant l'amour de sa vie
quitter son château à tout jamais
malgré sa présence dans le comics
fantastique fort 87 ou encore submariner
20 ce qui va nous intéresser désormais
c'est la saga de comics à stony shing
tales soit en gros les comptes étonnant
qu'ils vont nous montrer plusieurs
histoires mettant en vedette doom et qui
du coup permettent d'approfondir son
personnage dans les comics 1 à 3 de
cette nouvelle saga nous allons faire
face à une rébellion en latvérie car
effectivement vous savez désormais les
origines du docteur doom ce dernier est
très loin d'être issu d'une famille
royale donc ce qui veut dire que la
latvérie dôme a en fait pris le pouvoir
de lui même et a conquis cette nation
car il en avait les capacités rudolfo le
prince légitime de la latvérie va donc
mener une rébellion pour reprendre le
pouvoir sauf que doom est beaucoup trop
puissant et il va éradiquer cette
mutinerie en détruisant son propre
royaume après la reconstruction de ces
derniers passons directement aux comics
6 et 7 ou le docteur doom va commencer à
s'intéresser aux wakanda pour récupérer
le précieux vibranium détenu par la
nation ce qui va nous conduire à un
affrontement très intéressant entre xala
et le docteur doom
car oui je pense qu'il est bon de le
rappeler mais les deux protagonistes
sont des rois et les dirigeants de leurs
peuples respectifs
et d'ailleurs je pense que c'est un bon
moment pour le souligner malgré que doom
soit un antagoniste qui n'a pas peur de
commettre des atrocités et bien c'est un
leader très respecté et apprécié son
peuple bon même s'il ya eu une rébellion
effectivement tchalla va remettre en
cause les agissements de doom le
désignant comme un véritable tyran alors
que tchalla lui est un roi à l'ecoute
est très soucieux de son peuple mais le
truc c'est que grâce au pouvoir et à la
puissance de doom et bien les habitants
de la latvérie son protégé est à l'abri
la latvérie possède un très faible taux
de criminalité et en plus de cela depuis
que doom est aux commandes la nation n'a
jamais été aussi prospères et en
développement alors il est clair que
chez certains habitants il pourrait y
avoir une sorte de syndrome de stockholm
du style ils sont tombés amoureux leurs
ravisseurs un quart après touba douma a
pris le pouvoir et le royaume sans
demander puis il est clair qu'il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas ravis de la voir au
pouvoir cela explique notamment la
rébellion puis étant donné que doom est
beaucoup trop puissant personne n'ose
interposés pas même les pays voisins qui
ont peur de subir un véritable incident
diplomatique
néanmoins quand même il existe une
grande majorité de gens qui sont
contents de l'avoir au pouvoir pour des
raisons que j'ai énoncé auparavant bref
et du coup nous arrivons aux comics que
je trouve le plus intéressant de cette
saga et qui va conclure l'épopée de doom
dans à stony shing times c'est le comics
numéro 8 qui va soulever quelque chose
de très important concernant le dr doom
c'est le cas de sa mère dans les sombres
couloirs du château boris conduit un
doctor doom très silencieux et très
stressée vers le donjon les habitants
témoins que quelque chose se trame là
bas vont nous révéler par une scène
d'exposition que chaque année le 31
décembre leur souverain invoquerait
apparemment dans son donjon des démons
qu'il combattrait toute la nuit car en
fait étant donné que sa mère était une
sorcière et qu'elle est décédé dans des
conditions apparemment inconnu de tous
et bien sa mort l'aurait rendu maudite
ce qui fait qu'elle est en fait piéger
dans les enfers la légende que se
racontent les habitants à propos de leur
monarque nous est directement confirmé
quand nous repassons dans le point de
vue de doctor doom il nous sera révélé
qu'en plus le 31 décembre quand nous
passons d'une année à une autre c'est le
moment où la barrière entre le monde et
les autres dimensions est la plus fine
n'ayant jamais véritablement connu sa
mère et désireux de la libérer des
griffes des enfers doom chaque année
rentrer en contact avec le monarque de
cette autre dimension pour négocier la
libération de l'âme de sa mère par le
biais d'un affrontement vicieux qui
amuse le roi du royaume des damnés doom
est dans l'obligation d'affronter le
champion des enfers sauf que
malheureusement à chaque fois chaque
année et celle ci comprise dom ne
parvient pas à défaire son ennemi est
l'âme de sa mère reste donc piégé dans
les enfers doom fini alors à chaque fois
dévastés dans les bras de boris qui est
la seule épaule sur laquelle le docteur
peut se reposer avec ce comics nous
faisons face à quelque chose d'inédit
concernant le docteur doom et qui permet
de comprendre l'essence même de son
personnage en fait par le biais de son
histoire nous savons désormais que doom
est en guerre avec
l'humanité il est dans une quête de
vengeance par rapport à la mort de ses
parents depuis son plus jeune âge et qui
va même donner naissance à l'identité de
doctor doom le truc c'est que là où la
mort de son père a été provoquée par un
simple petit baron ridicule dont le
titre de noblesse symbolisait le pouvoir
dum alors qu'il était encore qu'un jeune
adulte a pu facilement le surpasser et
l'humilier lui et ses semblables à grâce
à son génie et son intelligence mais là
avec sa mère c'est une autre paire de
manches bien que doom soit un sorcier ce
n'est pas un excellent sorcier à
l'exception de certaines entités et la
magie est quelque chose qui s'enseigne
prenez le cas de doctor strange par
exemple ou encore quelqu'un comme au
rwanda dans les comics ils ont toujours
eu des mentors dans la magie doom est un
véritable autodidacte il n'a jamais rien
eu de plus que la malle appartenant à sa
mère contenant son héritage et cela lui
fait défaut c'est pourquoi doom est dans
une quête de supériorité même si sa
guéguerre avec reed richards l'a poussé
à se surpasser en termes de science sa
véritable quête pour devenir une entité
suprême sur tous les aspects c'est parce
que sa mère est la seule épine du pied
qui lui reste sa vengeance par rapport à
la mort de son père a largement été
atteinte mais concernant celle de sa
mère ce n'est jamais arrivé tout
simplement parce que doctor doom n'est
pas encore assez puissants ni supérieur
la vie va donc reprendre tranquillement
son cours nous retrouvons dôme dans
plusieurs comics comme celui d'audi
incredible hulk 143 où le souverain
cherchera à manipuler un banner en
cavale à cause des dégâts qu'il a causés
en tant que hulk nous le retrouvons
également dans un comics spéciale
mettant en vedette le groupe de musique
kiss ou encore dans la saga de comics
super vilaine team up créée à l'occasion
afin de compléter la saga marvel team up
il réapparaîtra dans le comics de iron
man numéro 150 ou doom est au niveau
s'affronter ou encore la saga principale
des 4 fantastiques pour continuer
d'agrémenter l'histoire dont notamment
la trilogie de numéro 2 158 à 260 là bas
nous sommes clairement témoin de la
situation prospère de la latvérie nous y
voyons un dr doom en train de gérer son
pays est partagée avec son peuple nous y
apprenons même que le monarque possède
un petit protégé un jeune garçon dont il
a repris l'éducation christophe verna
rld sauf que les hommes de main de doom
vont faire la découverte de l'ancien
héros de galactus gisant sur le sol dom
va le soigner et se servir de lui pour
le confronter aux quatre fantastiques
sauf que
la bataille va prendre une tournure que
doom n'avait pas du tout prévu et le
silver surfer va lui aussi rejoindre le
combat c'est alors qu et nous arrivons à
l'année 1984 une année qui je pense doit
rappeler des souvenirs pour les plus
anciens fans de comics d'entre vous
c'est l'arrivée de la toute première
saga de marvel super heroes sicre et
wars soit en gros les guerres secrètes
pour faire simple à l'époque suite à la
demande de la marque mattel pour
relancer la hype des super héros est
donc relancé la vente de figurines
marvel organise un événement particulier
où ils vont réunir la totalité de leur
propriété c'est à dire créer la réunion
de toutes les plus grandes entités de
l'univers marvel pour faciliter tout ça
et permettre à nos personnages de se
rencontrer de manière cohérente le
studio va donner naissance à une entité
du nom de beyond d'heure le beyond
d'heure à cette époque il faut vraiment
le voir comme une sorte de modérateur du
monde de marvel il est ultra cosmique il
est au delà de tout ce que l'on peut
imaginer bref il sert surtout de cause
et d'objectifs pour nos personnages par
le biais d'une planète façonné à partir
de morceaux d'autres planètes est
désigné comme le battle world le be
under va convoquer est téléporté la
totalité des personnages principaux de
l'univers marvel pour que ces derniers
s'affrontent et les gagnants pourront
obtenir tout ce qu'ils ont toujours
désirer car le be under est au dessus de
tout et est capable de tout nos
personnages à leur arrivée seront
séparés en deux teams l'équipe des super
héros et l'équipe des méchants bien
évidemment le docteur doom fait partie
du jeu et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir à quel point le personnage va se
démarquer de tous les autres et se
hisser en tant que grand vainqueur déjà
alors que tout le monde cherche
naturellement à coopérer et appliquer
les règles du jeu du be under doctor
doom se détache du groupe pour
comprendre qui est cette nouvelle entité
ayant été témoin de la puissance de
l'être divin qui a même repoussé
galactus qui a tenté d'enfreindre les
règles doctor doom suspecte une
puissance infinie chez le be under et si
ce dernier existe bel et bien
cela veut dire qu'il est possible de le
confronter et de lui voler ses pouvoirs
doom va alors chercher le soutien des
méchants et des héros dans cette
nouvelle quête sauf que personne ne sera
réceptif à son appel très déçu de voir à
quel point les autres ne réfléchissent
pas autant que lui et à quel point
personne ne voit plus loin que le bout
de son nez le protagoniste va alors
effectué ce qu'il sait faire de mieux
pliez les autres à sa volonté le docteur
va imposer son commandement aux autres
méchants de battles world par le biais
du tronc qui l'a reconstruit à lui tout
seul est reprogrammé pour en faire son
garde du corps en tant que leader né
doom va gérer l'équipe des villes d'une
main de maître grâce à lui ils
réussiront à neutraliser les super héros
par le biais de son intelligence doom va
même donner naissance sur battles world
à titania et volkan à 2 humaine acquis
doom a fait des expériences pour leur
octroyer des pouvoirs et grossir les
rangs de son équipe à terme doom n'a pas
oublié son plan de base qui est de
défaire le beyond d'heure une fois bien
installé avec sa team de méchant ce
dernier va utiliser le vaisseau monde de
galactus récemment apparue pour trouver
des réponses finalement ce dernier
n'aura rien trouvé de spécial mais
réussira à ramener ulysse clos à la vie
dont l'énergie est ré dans le vaisseau
de galactus et c'est là que
l'intelligence de doom va changer le
cours de l'histoire galactus qui ne
supporte plus sa faim cosmique se
retrouve obligé de manger son propre
vaisseau c'est alors qu'un nouveau plan
va émerger dans la tête de doom étant
donné que clos est désormais relié au
vaisseau de galactus doom va se servir
de lui pour absorber l'énergie que le
dévoreur de mondes est en train de
consommer une fois les pouvoirs volées
d'où me devient l'être le plus puissant
de battles world à l'exception bien sûr
du bion d'heure ne pouvant désormais
rien faire de plus sur la planète dr
doom décide de confronter l'être divin
et rien ne semble pouvoir l'arrêter
malheureusement le be under est beaucoup
trop puissant doom sera anéantie
ils ont sur le sol dans un long silence
le docteur doom très mal en point est en
train de mourir c'est alors que le
bneder va commencé à sonder l'esprit et
le corps de celui qui a tout tenté pour
se mesurer à lui nous sommes témoins de
la totalité de ce qui a composé la vie
du docteur doom les injustices qu'il a
subie est un enfant la mort de ses
parents son accident qui l'a défiguré sa
quête pour libérer l'âme de sa mère des
griffes de méphisto tout est passé au
peigne fin et alors qu'un simple mortel
aimerait que l'on lui abrège ses
souffrances le docteur doom est toujours
en vie et plus le bio d'heure sonde la
vie du personnage plus ce dernier trouve
la volonté de vivre dans son agonie le
docteur va lever le bras dans le but de
récupérer son armure et se relever et là
un immense tremblement de terre va
surgir le dr doom réapparait plus en
forme que jamais guéri de ses blessures
et nous affirme que le be under est mort
désormais en possession des pouvoirs
divins de l'être suprême le docteur doom
enlève son masque et annonce la fin des
guerres secrètes abassourdi les héros
sont très inquiet de savoir que le
docteur doom est désormais omnipotent
car ils connaissent le personnage ils
savent qu'il est ces derniers vont donc
s'entretenir avec ce nouveau dieu et
doom à la surprise générale affirme
qu'il souhaite utiliser ses nouveaux
pouvoirs à des fins altruiste cependant
nos héros n'arrive pas à avoir confiance
en lui et souhaite à l'unanimité se
rebeller contre le monarque dôme
désormais omnipotent sera témoin de la
conversation des avengers et en un
claquement de doigts il va atomiser le
groupe de super héros toujours
accompagné de clos qui l'a récemment
ressuscité le serviteur va commencer à
semer le doute dans la tête de son
maître concernant la mort des avengers
doctor doom qui jusque là était très
serein va commencer à perdre la tête et
le contrôle de ces nouveaux pouvoirs les
avengers vont revenir en force et quand
doom sera totalement affaibli à cause de
ses nouveaux pouvoirs le be under va
nous révéler qu'il était en fait dans le
corps de chloé qu'il a semé le trouble
dans la tête de doom dans le but que le
docteur perdre pied lui permettant par
la suite de reprendre ses pouvoirs une
fois restaurée à son état normal le be
under va bannir doom 2 battle world et
les héros vont commencer à retourner
chez eux quel bazar en vrai la première
saga de sucre et wars est hyper
intéressante pour voir à quel point le
docteur doom est unique et réussi à se
démarquer des autres personnages pour en
plus nous proposer une apogée dans son
histoire bien qu'il ne soit qu'un simple
mortel la volonté de doom est tellement
puissante que cela lui a permis de se
hisser au rang d' être le plus puissant
de tout l'univers il est au final le
gagnant des guerres secrètes
même si bon voilà le billon d'heure
avait tout manigancé pour étudier les
grands personnages de la terre néanmoins
je dois vous dire la vérité quelque
chose ne va pas dans cette histoire
effectivement vous avez dû le remarquer
mais je ne vous ai pas fait part de
l'entièreté de l'histoire de la trilogie
de comics fantastique fort de 158 à 260
et bien c'est désormais le moment de
vous le révéler et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi je le fait que maintenant en
fait dans le comics 260 paru un an avant
la sortie de marvel super heroes sicre
et wars le docteur doom a été tué dans
le combat opposant les deux anciens
héros de galactus et c'est là que le
problème survient car sicre et wars se
déroulant après cet événement est bien
doctor doom n'aurait pas dû être
présents alors que s'est-il réellement
passé et bien la raison a été expliquée
seulement deux ans après les événements
de sucre et wars dans le comics 288 des
4 fantastiques
en fait au moment de la bataille
opposant le surfeur d'argent et hijos le
docteur doom à utiliser le savoir qu'il
a acquis auprès des eaux void à l'époque
pour changer de corps sauf que désireux
de retrouver sa forme d'origine
l'antagoniste va invoquer le plus grand
pouvoir de lui vers par le biais d'un
sortilège et à la surprise générale le
beyond d'heure va apparaître reid
richard's présente pendant l'événement
sera sous le choc car je vous le
rappelle mais nous sommes après les
événements de sucre et wars sauf que le
be under ne reconnaît pas le docteur
doom et inversement doom ne reconnaît
pas non plus le be under reid va
finalement comprendre la situation et
nous révéler que les protagonistes ne se
reconnaissent pas parce que le be under
sont dès lors à des gens mais étant
donné que doom et dans un autre corps ce
n'est plus la même aura que celle que
l'être divin a connu et du coup doom ne
reconnaît pas le be under car pendant
les événements de sicre et war l'être
divin s'est basé sur les souvenirs des
héros pour amener doom ce qui fait qu'il
a en fait convoquer un doom du futur qui
a retrouvé son véritable corps afin
d'éviter un conflit temporel et continue
la boucle que le be under a instauré
l'être divin va redonner à doom sa
véritable forme elle envoyait dans le
passé pour effectuer les guerres
secrètes jusqu'au moment de son
bannissement par le beyond d'heure de
battles world et maintenant il est temps
de parler du comics que je préfère
concernant le docteur doom il s'agit de
doctor strange n doctor doom triumph
nternet sortie le 27 juin 89 c'est le
comics qui va enfin nous apporter une
conclusion concernant la mère de doctor
doom alors que la vie mène
tranquillement son cours le sorcier du
bij enti genghis lance un appel à tous
les sorciers des arts mystiques à
travers le monde pour un tournoi qui
permettrait de désigner qui serait apte
à devenir un sorcier suprême beaucoup de
sorciers vont répondre à son appel et
ils vont tous se réunir dans le lieu
indiqué bien évidemment nous y
retrouvons le docteur strange l'actuel
sorcier suprême très respecté et
approuvé des autres sorciers sauf que
tout à coup un invité surprise se joint
à la fête il s'agit du docteur doom les
autres personnages seront interloquée de
voir le souverain de la latvérie mais le
docteur doom bel et bien un sorcier il
est clair que doom n'a pas suivi la même
route que ses compatriotes concernant
les arts mystiques mais ce dernier est
quelqu'un de sensible à la magie il la
connaît elle l'a déjà pratiqué doom a
entendu l'appel de genghis comme tous
les autres sorciers et c'est pourquoi il
est venu à l'issue de l'épreuve strange
remporte le concours néanmoins steven a
gagné alors que doctor doom étaient
encore en lice du coup le sorcier
genghis lui ordonne par le biais du
vigeant ty accordé sa bénédiction au
docteur doom ce qui signifie en gros de
lui rendre un service ce trench va alors
s'indigner car le dr doom est considéré
comme un tyran et le sorcier suprême n'a
pas du tout envie d'aider le souverain
dans ses manigances c'est alors que doom
n'ayant jamais oublier sa véritable
quête va profiter de l'occasion d'avoir
le soutien de strange pour lui proposer
de l'aider à récupérer l'âme de sa mère
prisonnière d enfer la tâche étant
plutôt noble le docteur strange
acceptera la requête en route vers la
latvérie le docteur strange en tant qu
invité de marque du docteur doom sera
témoin de l'histoire profonde de ce
dernier et réussira au final à se
détendre car après avoir appris à se
connaître steven va réaliser que doom
est beaucoup plus humain qui ne le
pensait la nuit tombe et boris le loyal
serviteur de doom depuis son plus jeune
âge conduire à strange à sa chambre et
sur le chemin les deux hommes vont
engager une conversation à propos du
souverain steven vote en savoir plus sur
l'homme complexe que symbolise doom et
la quête qui lui a été imposée boris va
alors lui raconter en détail l'histoire
de cynthia la mère de victor et comment
cela a façonné le jeune homme à devenir
le monarque froid et puissant qu'il est
aujourd'hui à l'époque alors que le camp
deegan subi une nouvelle fois une
répression de la part du baron voisin
qui considèrent les gens du camp comme
nuisible c'en est trop pour la jeune
sorcière cynthia von doom qui n'en peut
plus de voir son peuple et ses proches
souffrir sauf que la jeune sorcière va
faire la terrible erreur de trouvé comme
solution de faire appel à méphisto le
célèbre démons va manipuler cynthia et
lui octroyer 1 immense pouvoir pour
qu'elle puisse réaliser sa vengeance
malheureusement c'est seulement après
son action qu'elle va s'en rendre compte
mais méphisto lui octroyer le pouvoir et
non le contrôle de ce dernier cynthia
qui a libéré toute sa puissance pour
tuer les gardes qui méprisait ses amis
en fait fait beaucoup plus de dégâts
qu'elle ne l'a imaginé énormément
d'innocents ont été tuées à cause de son
sortilèges y compris des enfants et dans
un moment d'inattention
alors que cindy a est effondrée car elle
s'est rendu compte de ce qu'elle vient
de faire un garde qui avait survécu à
l'attaqué achève la jeune femme dans le
dos de retour dans le présent de bon
matin strange va commencer à entraîner
le docteur doom à mieux maîtriser ses
pouvoirs magiques car même si d'hommes
est un sorcier il reste un autodidacte
qui s'est simplement formé par le biais
des notes et artefacts appartenant à sa
mère et connaissant la dangerosité de la
mission et les nombreuses défaites de
dôme face à méphisto par le passé chaque
31 décembre il faut que le monarque soit
prêt surprenamment strange et doom forme
un très bon duo et réussissent à mettre
à mal méphisto c'est alors que le démon
ayant plus d'un tour dans son sac va
isoler le docteur doom pour s'entretenir
avec lui ça chante à quel point cette
quête est importante pour le personnage
mephisto va proposer l'âme de dr strange
en échange de celle de sa mère bien
évidemment le monarque va accepter et le
marché va s'opérer pour la première fois
depuis son intégration dans l'histoire
des comics doctor doom face à sa mère va
verser une larme et ne pourra pas
s'empêcher de la prendre dans ses bras
sauf que cynthia n'est pas dupe elle
connaît très bien méphisto si ce dernier
a bien voulu la libérer c'est parce que
doom a dû faire quelque chose d'horrible
méphisto malin comme il est ne va pas
tarder à révéler la vérité à cynthia son
fils victor vient dé changer la vie d'un
innocent pour sauver celle de sa mère
horrifiée de ce que son fils est devenu
et de ce qu'il a osé faire pour la
sauver cynthia n'acceptera pas de suivre
son fils malgré les supplices de ce
dernier alors que méphisto se réjouit
d'avoir trompé doom et en plus d'avoir
le docteur strange à sa merci steven va
finalement réussir à se libérer
pas de n'importe quelle manière en
réalité doom n'a jamais prévu de laisser
tomber steven il n'a jamais souhaité
échanger l'âme de ce dernier contre
celle de sa mère discrètement il avait
mis un dispositif dans la main de steven
qui lui permettrait de se libérer et de
s'échapper une fois cynthia à l'abri les
deux hommes vont donc engager de nouveau
le combat contre méphisto qui a été dupé
par doom et vont tenter par tous les
moyens de protéger la statue inerte
contenant l'âme de cynthia durant le
combat grâce aux arts mystiques et aux
intentions pures de cynthia de ne pas
prendre l'avis de steven contre la
sienne strange va réussir à racheter
l'âme de cette dernière qui quittera la
réalité de méphisto pour connaître le
repos éternel les deux hommes
parviendront par la suite à s'échapper
et à retourner au château où boris les
attend doctor strange sera totalement
chamboulé de cette expérience doom
aurait pu le trahir mais il ne l'a pas
fait et en plus de cela cette
manipulation pour emprisonner
temporairement strange dans le but de
libérer l'âme de sa mère aura coûté à
doom l'amour de ces dernières envers son
fils
cet arc et je trouve incroyable et
démontre à quel point le personnage de
dr doom est profond l'identité de victor
vendôme n'existe plus seul le docteur
doom a survécu et le monarque en a
parfaitement conscience tout le long de
sa vie le souverain s'est muré dans sa
solitude dans le but de devenir le
puissant et solide personnage qu'il est
aujourd'hui le fils de cynthia est mort
il ya des années donc si le prix de la
liberté de la sorcière et l'amour de
cette dernière pour son fils et bien
soit pour le docteur doom la souffrance
c'est comme la compassion ou l'affection
ce sont des choses qui caractérise
simplement les humains inférieur les
émotions ne symbolise plus rien du tout
pour doctor doom bon et bien évidemment
après cette péripétie le docteur
réapparaîtra à 2 multiples reprises dans
de nombreux comics toujours plus
passionnants les uns que les autres mais
je pense qu'il est désormais grand temps
de conclure cette vidéo avec l'événement
majeur qui je pense vous intéresse tous
la seconde saga ce secret wars paru en
2015 tout d'abord il faut poser les
bases l'histoire de six crétoise
commence par le biais de la saga de
comics new avengers volume 3 sortie en
2013 les illuminati l'équipe ultra
secrète réunissant les super-héros les
plus puissants et les plus influents de
la terre vont être témoin d'un phénomène
très inquiétant où ils vont apercevoir
la terre d'un autre univers se
rapprocher très dangereusement de la
leur il s'agit d'une incursion et ils ne
le savent pas encore mais c'est la
première d'une longue série qui va
aboutir à la fin du multivers ce qui est
vraiment intéressant avec cette saga qui
précèdent l'événement sicre et wars
c'est de voir les choix de chacun ou
comment ces derniers vont réagir face
aux batailles imposé par le multivers et
bien évidemment si on en parle c'est
parce que le docteur doom encore une
fois va émerger en tant qu'entité
central du scénario et nous proposer une
apogée ultime pour son personnage alors
que les illuminati sont contraints de
faire face aux incursions les poussant à
commettre les pires atrocités soin de
détruire les mondes et tous ses
habitants qui menace de s'écraser sur
leurs terres nous apprenons au fur et à
mesure que l'histoire avance de
l'existence d'être lié aux multivers
notamment un certain rabou mme halal
désigné comme le grand destructeur et
dont les disciples parcours le multivers
pour engendrer des incursions c'est
alors qu'une nouvelle collision liés à
la terre 616 va se déclarer sauf que le
point d'incursions se trouve être le
pays de la latvérie le royaume du
docteur doom et chose encore plus
improbable l'incursion dans le dr doom
est victime est liée à la menace des
maps makers des sortes de pirates du
multivers qui ont cartographié ce
dernier et qui cherche à contrer les
actions de ce fameux arabe oum halal le
grand destructeur finalement grâce aux
actions secrète des illuminati la terre
616 a été sauvé pour cette bataille et
la latvérie ayant été le point
d'incursion de la collision le dr doom
est désormais affiliés à cette bataille
du multivers dont il va commencer à
prendre parti par le biais d'un rocher
provenant de la planète d'en face dont
les map maker se faisait partie doom
avec ses hommes vont commencer à
l'analyser et vont réussir grâce à sa
signature énergétique à découvrir le
plan total du multivers et des
incursions appartenant au map maker sauf
que étrange la signature énergétique du
rocher cache un autre secret c'est en
fait la même signature que celle de
molécules man alias owen rhys et doom
veut comprendre pourquoi après quelques
péripéties les deux hommes auront
compris exactement tout ce qui se trame
il s'avère que l'ebit en dehors ce sont
en train d'effectuer une expérience dans
le but d'anéantir le multivers en un
seul coup et pour arriver à cet objectif
ils se sont servis de molécules man et
en ont fait une bombe à retardement dans
chaque univers c'est à dire que lorsque
le personnage va mourir et ce dans
chaque monde il emportera avec lui son
univers dans sa chute dr doom accompagné
du owen rhys de la terre 616 se
donneront alors pour mission de tuer la
totalité des molécules man à travers le
temps et l'espace ce qui engendrera une
multitude d'incursion et au final pour
mener à bien cette mission il nous sera
révélé que le docteur doom a tant fait
ériger une religion où ce dernier en est
le courant s'ouvre à doctor doom et
arabe oum halal et l'a toujours été il
est le grand destructeur par le biais de
sa religion ses disciples l'aide à mener
à bien sa mission de tuer la totalité
des molécules man à travers le multivers
à terme grâce à la condition unique de
wayne qui est relié au be under et qui a
pu absorber air également le pouvoir de
ces autres lui même ce dernier a servi
de conduits pour octroyer à doom un
pouvoir inégalé quand ils ont fait face
au but on dort étant donné que molécules
man est relié justement molécule dôme
avec son nouveau pouvoir lors de la
dernière incursion opposant les deux
derniers univers va donner naissance à
une planète bâti à partir de plusieurs
morceaux des restes du multivers battle
world devenu le gode empereur doom le
monarque dirige désormais l'univers dont
il a donné naissance il fondera la garde
des torts il fera de doctor strange son
shérif et depuis son château comme il le
faisait en lattes very il cherchera à
construire un monde meilleur à son image
grâce à lui des millions de personnes
ont pu survivre à la fin du multivers
malheureusement doctor doom reste doctor
doom ce dernier n'a jamais été un dieu
et alors que son initiative de fond des
battles world était pure permettant la
survie de l'humanité
la nature de doom revient rapidement au
galop le protagoniste redeviendra
facilement un tir en faisant taire ses
opposants
il va même tuer son shérif et amis
proches docteur strange car ce dernier
commençait à perdre foi en son maître le
dieu empereur doom a en fait peur de
l'évolution de son univers il est
beaucoup trop attaché à ce qu'il a bâti
et n'a aucunement envie de perdre le
pouvoir ou le contrôle de battles world
c'est alors que reed richard's son rival
de toujours va intervenir est allé à la
rencontre de molécules man ayant
conscience des défauts de victor que
tout le monde considère comme un dieu
reid va parler avec owen dont il sait
qu'il est la source du pouvoir de doom
l'empereur ayant pris connaissance des
agissements de reed va intervenir et le
confronter monsieur fantastique va alors
admettre qu'il admire doom pour avoir
réussi à sauver le multivers sauf qu'il
aurait pu faire tellement mieux victor
est tellement accroché à son pouvoir et
à son titre d'empereur dieu que battle
world ce n'est désormais plus un monde
paisible mais le terrain de jeu d'un tir
en molécules man la source des pouvoirs
de doom est présent pendant le combat va
considérer les deux protagonistes comme
étant sur un même pied d'égalité owen va
donc également octroyé ses pouvoirs à
reed richards
et monsieur fantastique 20 mettre un
terme à battle world et grâce aux
molécules man va relancer le multivers à
l'instar de doom vide croix à
l'expansion de la vie et de toute chose
et grâce à son action le multivers va
renaître et donner naissance à une
nouvelle saga où les habitants de
battles world seront libres de mener la
vie qu'ils veulent mener le docteur doom
sera de retour en live et riz était
moins que les cicatrices sur son visage
ont disparu se mettra à rire
le principal défaut du docteur doom
c'est de ne pas réussir à faire
confiance aux autres comme démontré dans
ses premiers comics ou encore son
origine story le personnage souhaite
prendre sa revanche sur l'humanité qui
ne lui a jamais fait de cadeau est pire
que ça qui lui a pris ses deux parents
depuis qu'il est devenu orphelin victor
est dans une quête de supériorité où il
cherchera à devenir quelqu'un de
toujours plus puissants tout ce qu'il a
accompli depuis le début il l'a fait
simplement par la force de sa volonté à
prendre la science maîtriser la magie
devenir le souverain de la latvérie
gagné la première édition des guerres
secrètes tout ça victor l'a fait tout
seul il n'a pas besoin des autres il se
suffit à lui-même mais malheureusement
c'est aussi sa plus grande faiblesse
même si la volonté de victor lui a
permis de passer de simple être humain à
entité divine le fait qu'ils ne fassent
confiance qu'à lui-même le pousse à
commettre des atrocités pour garder le
contrôle du pouvoir dans le fond le
docteur doom n'est pas quelqu'un de si
mauvais et nous l'a prouvé à plusieurs
reprises quand il a réussi à prendre le
pouvoir du bion d'heure ils souhaitaient
s'en servir à des fins altruiste quand
il a donné naissance à battle world son
action l'ua permis de sauver l'humanité
est gardé en vie des millions de
personnes qui auraient dû mourir à cause
de la fin du multivers et les héros
comme reed richards ont conscience de
tout ça mais la nature de victor dont la
lourde histoire l'a façonnée à devenir
qui il est aujourd'hui le poussera à
toujours rendre ces actions altruistes
imparfaite le docteur doom aurait pu
être le plus grand héros que l'univers
marvel n'ai jamais connu mais à cause de
ses souffrances du passé dont les
cicatrices lui rappelle constamment son
vécu victor omnubilé par la perfection
est au final un être imparfait des
armées pour devenir l'empereur dieu de
l'univers un titre qu'il a toujours
convoité la conclusion de sucre et wars
et je trouve du coup parfaite pour le
personnage car dôme sera contraint de
redevenir simplement le souverain du
royaume de la latvérie mais étant donné
qu'au final grâce à lui l'humanité a
survécu et le multivers à puce relancer
la guérison de ses blessures peut être
vu comme une sorte de présent lui
permettant de se libérer désormais de
son passé et le remercier pour ses
actions et tout ce que je vous raconte
depuis le début de la vidéo et bien
c'est tout ça qui rend doctor doom si
unique
et voilà la vidéo est désormais terminée
et bon sens cela n'aura pas été simple
docteur doom et vraiment je trouve
l'antagoniste ultime de l'univers marvel
et son histoire est tellement riche il
est tellement omniprésent qu'il a été
très difficile de prioriser les comics
que je souhaitais vous montrez bien
évidemment du coup j'ai dû faire
abstraction de plusieurs histoires il
existe une multitude de comics
formidable mettant en lumière doctor
doom et de nouvelles histoires mais
j'estime que la vidéo suffit à vous
démontrer à quel point le personnage est
si unique n'hésitez pas à me faire un
maximum de retours concernant la vidéo
comme vous le savez c'est un concept qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur donc
vos commentaires sont très importants
pour que je puisse m'améliorer
et savoir si bas cela vous plaît
toujours autant ce type de vidéos
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus qui
soutient énormément travail et à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper les prochains
pourquoi sont ils si unique j'ai adoré
mettre en lumière l'histoire du docteur
doom qui est un personnage que
j'apprécie vraiment beaucoup et j'espère
que ma passion vous a été transmise sur
ce set et argo rock que le line rares
soit avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]